سعيد بالرحمه مهاجر لا يعرف الفرنسيه صنع
مجدا بقدمين حافيتين
[موسيقى]
يمتلك سعيد بالرحمه حكايه تشبه الاف
وملايين الاطفال وسواء في الجزائر او
العالم العربي او حول العالم الا ان هذه
الحكايات عاده لا تكتمل الا من خلال
رحلتكاح تمتد لسنوات منذ طفولته تلك وحتى
يصبح نجما عالميا
اليوم بات بالرحمه نجما بالفعل ولكن الفصل
الاهم في حياته هو الفصل الذي سبق كل ذلك
والذي مشى فيه النجم الجزائري الخطوات
الاصعب منذ البدايه ظهرت علامات الموهبه
على بالرحمه في مدينه وهران الجزائريه حيث
اعتاد اللعب حافي القدمين منذ السادسه من
عمره
ولكن اللحظه الاصعب في مسيرته حانت في
الثانيه عشره من عمره حين اضطر لمغادره
الجزائري الى فرنسا مع والدته وهناك تحولت
حياته بالكامل
الانفصال عن الاب لم يكن سهلا بالنسبه
لصبي يبلغ من العمر 12 عاما فقط خاصه وان
بالرحمه كان يمتلك علاقه خاصه مع والده
الذي كان داعما كبيرا له طوال حياته وعلى
ذكر والده فان وفاته كانت ضربه قسيمه
لحياه بالرحمه واثرت عليه كثيرا ما جعله
يغير الرقم قميصه من الرقم تسعه الى الرقم
22 والذي كان الرقم المفضل لوالده حيث
اهداه قميصه مدى الحياه ليظل يتذكره دوما
لم يكن بالرحمه يستطيع التحدث بالفرنسيه
واضطر الى تعلمها جنبا الى جنب مع
استمراره في ممارسه كره القدم التي تستحوذ
على الجزء الاكبر من الجهد والتفكير
بطبيعه الحال عدم اتقانه للفرنسيه جعله
مثلا للسخريه بين زملائه ولكن تلك التجربه
حسب رايه كانت مفيده حيث ساعدته على تعلم
المثابره وبناء شخصيته وسط كل الصعوبات
[موسيقى]
تنقل بالرحمه بين العديد من الانديه
الصغيره حتى جاءت التجربه التي مثلت له
نقطه التحول خلال عامين قضاهما في نادي
نيس وستظهر في الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه ليست
بالافضل الا ان حرمه بان يصبح لاعبا
محترفا كان ملذه الدائم للصبر على كل ما
يعانيه
وبعد انتقاله من نيس الى شاتيورو في دوري
الدرجات الثانيه الفرنسيه كان امامه خيار
العوده لينيس او الذهاب الى انجلترا فقرر
حينها بدء مغامرات جديده في انجلترا لم
يكن بالرحمه يصدق انه سيلعب في الدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز خلال عامين فقط بعد
انتقاله الى عام 2018 ولكن ذلك حدث بالفعل
بعد انتقاله الى وست هام يونايتد عام 2020
في ويست هام بات بالرحمه احدا نجوم
البريميرليج وكذلك احد ابرز نجوم منتخب
الجزائر ليصل الى الفصل الاهم في حياته
والاكثر بريقا الا انه لولا الفصول الاولى
التي تحمل صعوباتها بكل شجاعه لما وصل
محارب الصحراء هنا
[موسيقى]